all right Chris yeah Chris how have you
been where have you been all right where
have you been where have I been uh just
on the streets of Los
Angeles I think you were in jail for a
while
uh
no on the
streets I think he I heard you were in
jail for robbing a a weed
shop uh
yeah no I wasn't sorry that was a false
memory do you think we can reshoot it
sure all right what
uh I was told you
were you were in jail for a while for uh
okay I was in jail for a while for like
uh a few
weeks but I didn't uh I didn't Rob
nothing no no
have you talked with your family your
dad I talked to my family
no I speak with your dad from time to
time are you taking any uh any of the
medications
that oh sh they probably prescribed for
you for your schizophrenia oh I don't
have schizophrenia you don't
no yes are you tell me what's going on
with you are you okay are you fine are
you in need of something I'm
okay
okay I'm fine I just been uh wanding the
streets
and doing crazy
uh
stuff what kind crazy stuff are you
doing smoking cigarettes
and uh finding good jokes to tell
people there we
go how you making money on the streets
uh just asking for
it just asking for
money people give you it people will
give you
money do I think people will give me
money people will give you money when
you're asking for it ah
yeah once in a while I get
money once in a while I Get Money
yeah are you using uh any of the drugs
that are out here no just cigarettes and
uh uh what do you call
it oh yeah I'm using drugs too crystal
meth
Crystal
uh senel you've tried fatyol too
yeah it's not
good yeah I can't make you
overdose I overdose once you overdosed
once yeah they saved you
yeah what else
next are you okay living this
life uh you know
I was hoping I could get a better life
how old are you now how old am I
now 28 you're 28 yeah no
27 at this age you could be doing things
with your
life it might lead you
somewhere at this age you could be doing
things with your life that that would be
better yeah might lead to a better
future
I should go get a
job what kind
of just picking it loves to pick
SCS do you have any any
friends anyone that you interact
with
uh
well
yeah anyone that i' interact with
uh I guess just anybody yeah yeah I'm
kind to
everybody oh okay are you happy
you're content with this
life oh uh I'm content with getting
another
life you might need to take some
medications to get there though
yeah oh God no what's wrong oh
yes H did
what sorry you keep asking I was just
saying stuff that was schizophrenic you
think you do have little schizoph
you uh
yeah just a little bit
Yeah does the crystal meth make that
situation worse or does it help with
it uh it
can can do both it balances it out
really is what that
meant oh
um
yeah and going to
a a hospital to maybe try to get some
treatment that might help you get your
old self back yeah is that something
you're open to yeah it
is yeah okay we'll talk to your dad
after this okay see see if
maybe we can uh connect
there all
right how do you spend your days how I
spend my days yeah what do you
do just chill and talk to
people you ever have anything happen to
you that's problem
IC nobody bothers you nobody robs you
nobody not much to Rob I
guess nobody robs me nobody disturbs me
it's
good yeah you go to the mission to eat
yeah do you sleep do I
sleep yeah every day you do every day
yeah a lot of people on crystal math
won't sleep every day yeah they'll sleep
once a week
maybe
yeah we can redo this if you want
sorry I don't
know
um you can sleep on crystal meth if you
get drowsy I'm sorry if you get drowsy
while you're on crystal myth you can
sleep you just pass out it's
sad oh
shoot so you in jail for a
bit
uh
no what was jail
like no I wasn't in
jail just for or sorry for like a few
weeks yeah wasn't bad it was
cold oh okay do you think this is uh
good enough yeah I think so I know that
your family is worried about you and all
right maybe we can try to put you guys
together and maybe does it for
me how long youve been out here on the
streets
uh you know I don't
know
huh who is
that do you think we can redo the
video Yeah know I think I think we're
good I'll let you
go